ich fange an mit dem was mich heute
besonders bewegt aber ich habe heute
noch mal so ein bisschen in die
wahlumfragen geguckt und dann gesehen
dass noch immer 10 11 12 prozent der
deutschen sich vorstellen können die afg
zu wählen und ihnen wirklich zu rufen
tun sie es nicht denn wenn sie fdp
wählen dann kriegen sie genau das was
sie auf den tod nicht leiden können ein
sehr sehr links links bündnis ja sie
haben richtig gehört wer afd wählt wählt
rot rot grün und das kommt so ihre
stimme für die afd verschwindet
sozusagen im bürgerlichen lager denn
weder die cdu noch die fdp wird mit der
afg koalieren die stimme ist insofern
auf dieser seite des politischen
spektrums verloren und mehr noch sie
macht das andere lager das links links
lager der rot-rot-grünen lager dadurch
stärker ist sowieso irgendwie komisch
man weiß gar nicht in diesem wahlkampf
das kriegt man eigentlich wenn man den
einen oder den anderen werden wir können
es mal kurz durchdeklinieren eigentlich
liegt nur der der olaf scholz wählt
wirklich olaf scholz weil der der armin
laschet wählt weiß meist gar nicht so
richtig was er kriegen sollte er der
christian linden und die fdp wählt der
meisten wird nicht wirklich um christian
lindner mitten im roten kanzler also
stolz koaliert oder dann doch mit einem
schwarzen nämlich armin laschet das ist
ein ziemliches durcheinander deshalb ist
es eigentlich ganz gut dass wenigstens
eins fest steht wer afd weltwelt
rot-rot-grün und deshalb sollten
politisch intelligent afd welle dieses
mal ihre stimme nicht bei ihrer partei
machen
ja da muss ich mal im prinzip zu stimmen
ja los ich afd wählen aber rot-rot-grün
wird es nicht geben da bin ich mir ganz
sicher ganz nicht geben weil weder die
spd noch die grünen das machen die
grünen glaube ich noch weniger als die
spd in der bei der spd gibt es
vermutlich auf den linken flügel einige
wie das ganz gerne hätten oder
jedenfalls versuchen würden die grünen
wären verrückt wenn sie es machen würden
denn die haben sich viele mitte wähler
angefressen im zuge des wahlkampfs viele
bürgerliche leute früher cdu gewählt
haben wählen jetzt die grünen die würden
sie sofort wieder verlieren wenn sie mit
den linken zusammengehen links ist
vorbei und das was die an überlegungen
an stellen wie sie so eine koalition
zusammenbringen könnten die linken
nämlich beispielsweise
indem sie sagen ja wir wollen ja gar
nicht aussteigen aus der nato wie wollen
sie auflösen das erfordert einen
allgemeinen beschluss der nato den
wirklich geben und dann sagen sie bei
militäreinsätzen im ausland können wir
ja die abstimmung im bundestag frei
geben ja gute nacht dann geht es ja
vogel wild durcheinander da ist die
koalition keinen pfifferling mehr wert
mit dieser partei wird niemand
zusammengehen werden wir
verhindern also wenn scholz die nase
vorn hat und es reicht für rot grün wer
ist und es reicht aber für rot grün
allein nicht ja wer soll das denn dann
verhindern und sage jetzt nicht die fdp
auch genau die euro also es gibt es gibt
aus meiner sicht zwei parteien von denen
wir jetzt schon wissen ich glaube das
fest dass sie regieren werden das ist
die fdp und die grünen jetzt geht es nur
noch darum wer für das laden an jamaika
ist presse am ende entweder aber jetzt
was ich aber jetzt also dann müssen wir
das noch einmal kurz ein bisschen
analytisch betrachten das ist ja der
erste die erste wahl die ich mit liebe
suchen wahl wahlversprechen bereits vor
der wahl gebrochen worden sind also
christian lindner ist gestartet um
dieses jahr mit auf keinen fall ampel
auf keinen fall ampel ich glaube hat
nicht gesagt nur über meine leiche aber
es hat wahrscheinlich gedacht das war
jetzt heiss
vielleicht mit allen und meine frage
lautet wie soll denn bei zwei themen
also klima gewöhnt und steuererhöhungen
die fdp jemals ihre punkte durchsetzen
ich begeistere sie eine große chance
dass wir das erste mal eine
dreier-koalition bekommen
und die können sich nur einigen indem
sie kompromisse gehen und die extreme
weg kommen also wähler also
wahlversprechen brechen sicher
kompromiss nachdem das man sagen wir
alleine regieren würden würden die
grünen ja anders agieren als in einer
dreier-koalition und dass die stimmen
der afd die können die gleichen
papierkorb werfen die können nicht am
wahlsonntag zu hause bleiben das ist
nützt ja nichts oder vorschlag das
gleiche gilt aber auch für links ich
glaube nicht dass es rot rot grün geben
wird es wird auch die linkspartei selber
noch zu sehen also die können
theoretisch das machen aber die kriegen
ihre dinger im bundesrat nicht durch und
deswegen glaube ich dass die fdp eine
ganz kalkulierbare größe ist es wird
sich um die fdp und die grünen die
regierung bilden frage ist jetzt einfach
ampel oder jammerte es gibt ja sogar
schon insel anführen darf in der fdp
kann das jetzt nicht namentlich
wiedergeben überlegungen dass sich die
fdp mit den grünen verständigt über den
partner mit dem sie dann nach der wahl
zusammen gehen bevor das überhaupt aus
gekapert wird also dass sie schon mal
miteinander reden unter zwei parteien
und dann sagen also passt mal auf der
liegt vorne mit dem versuchen wir es
jetzt allein das auch in meinen augen
grüne
liegen das ist ein grosser rat um so
weit liegen die gar nicht auseinander
also bleiben wir doch bei dem einen
punkt die einen sagen wir müssen die
steuern erhöhen und die anderen sagen
steuer höheren lohn über unsere leichen
das ist ja dann ziemlich wurscht womit
sie den die klima sachen bezahlen müssen
keine steuern erhöhen die meisterin
anders ja warum halt schulden so wendet
der eingangs these von dir zurückkehren
klaus sind bin ich auch ein bisschen
arrogant ich meine es gibt leute in
deutschland ein teil der bevölkerung der
die afd es sind elf prozent da muss man
jetzt erstmal sagen anstatt auf dem afd
wiederum zu hauen muss man erst mal
sagen die anderen parteien haben es
nicht geschafft zu überzeugen also die
union hat muss man ganz klar sagen es
sollte nie was rechts neben der union
sein hat die union vergeigt es wurde
offen für die afd dass aber ein irrtum
dass sie alle von der union kommen es
gibt
jedenfalls
gibt es schon allgemeinen parteien
versuchen und da ich finde wir sollten
nicht immer mit so einem ärger also mit
somit somit seine arroganz als
politikern habe darüber reden weil ich
kenne wir müssen die parteien auffordern
anstatt jetzt zu sagen wer fdp wählt
wählt man ist so ähnlich wie das ist
seit jahren und die etablierten
sozusagen parteien inzwischen sie auch
die afg schon annähernd etabliert haben
es eben nicht geschafft aber das sind
eben genau nicht etabliert keiner will
mit ihnen eine regierungskoalition gehen
aber
müsste man das ja man hat einfach nur
wirklich sagen wer afd wählt kann auch
und ungültigen stimmzettel abgeben es
nützt nichts egal wie viele stimmen die
afg bekommen sie wird nicht mitregieren
und da würde ich empfehlen jeder
wählerinnen und wähler will eine partei
die irgendwie hinterher eine chance hat
mitzuregieren oder den walzen auf syrien
aber es gibt bully zahl von wählern gehe
wählen aus protest die wollen gar nicht
mitregieren sondern die wollen den
anderen zeigen ja dann häufig doch wenn
schönes wetter ist ein jahr zu hause war
ja lange genug erlebt werden immer die
wenn die afg in ostdeutschland bei 25
prozent lag was denn hier los ging in
dem land das lassen die zu die wähler zu
hause umsetzen und haben sie amüsiert am
wahlabend genau das wollten sie ja das
werden sie jetzt nicht mehr kriegen weil
die fdp ist so ein bisschen bei trump
ähnlich ja ja ja weil die halbdistanz
die ist einfach zu schwach die ist
nichts mehr wert die ist durch ihn war
die partei und es wäre ganz gut wenn sie
jetzt mal durch viele das wird noch
nicht so weit seien aber vielleicht dann
vier jahre später muss man mal gucken
die linken durch
ich sage ja schon immer aber die spd
traut sich halt nicht sie muss sie
auffressen die müssen fusionieren dann
schluss mit allerdings banden die wache
ja manchmal waren sicher wenn man eure
politische einsicht nicht hat wie ich
beispielsweise ist man als laie im
moment in eine situation wo man sagt
egal wie es kommt mit der fdp wird es
nicht so schlimm das ist dass das ist
irgendwie so dass man ja gut die die bi
die wir werden den den linken ihre
steuer träume abkaufen die werden den
rechten oder den grünen ihre ihre
klimapolitik so so hinbiegen das und
erstaunlich nicht die werden einen
kompromiss machen okay von mir aus
solarpflicht für jedes gebäude und tempo
30 und autofreie innenstädte mit allen
vor und nachteilen es hat aber dafür
fangen die steuern die haben wir werden
solche die lieber montag sie haben doch
sonntag nacht wird die werden sehr guten
vorschlag zur finanzierung der klima
investitionen gemacht das nämlich ist
eine art von mammut abschreibung gibt
auf alle maschinen und einrichtungen die
dem klimaschutz dienen die werden in
zwei jahren abgeschrieben ja als
unternehmer weißt du was das bedeutet
dass ein großer anreiz
das doch viel besser als wenn der staat
ihre geld in die hand nimmt um das den
leuten zu schenken das ist doch viel
besser so das hat unternehmerischer
impuls da werden neue geräte entwickelt
die leute investieren
die wegen der meinung dass wir
nachhaltigkeit und umweltbewusstsein
benötigen aber nicht mit verboten
sondern mit erfindungen wir müssen in
der digitalisierung wie wir millionen
von strom nutzer mit anbietern mit strom
reserven speicherung das kann man alles
viel moderner machen wir können müssen
die die solar technik investieren in
wasserstoff dass wir brauchen dafür die
erfinder mit verboten machen wir
rückwärtsgewandte politik wir müssen
nach vorne kommen auch im
internationalen wettbewerb denn je mehr
wir abstellen wir haben ja den schrott
atomstrom von viel unsichereren
kraftwerken aus den nachbarländern hier
rein
aber ich bin mir sicher dass thomas
richter das war ein ganz wichtiger punkt
mit dem christian lindner wirkt aktuell
wie der heilsbringer es ist ja so auch
freunde von mir sagt ich will die fdp
sagen wir
sind top der schlag sagen macht
christian lindner deutschlands werte
unseres rettungsring für
deutschland
[Musik]